Now that we have seen a 2 bit predictor and how it works,
let's do a quiz on 2 bit predictors. Let's say, you have a 2 bit predictor,
that has the four states. The 00 state is the strong not taken.
Then we have the weak not taken, weak taken and the strong taken state.
Let's say that we start in the strong, not taken state. And remember,
that if we have a taken decision, we move towards the strong taken state and
stay there as long as we have a taken decision. But for a not taken decision, we
count down towards the strong not taken state. And stay there. The question for
you is, is there a sequence of branch outcomes that results in never predicting
correctly. So is there a sequence such that when we start in this state, and
here obviously we're predicting not taken, so the outcome needs to be taken. And
then after we update the predictor, we have to mis-predict again and
again. If yes, there is a sequence, then write the.
First five outcomes of that sequence here. If no, then put a check mark here.